[Musique]
robin
mais
tout
bah
oh
wood
et
[Musique]
il
après voici lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches les missions qui vous mange des
autres avec margaux hemingway c'est
terry de s'appeler margot depuis qu'on
est né d'être à l'eau jusqu'à la fin de
ses jours
bonsoir ans la révélation de l'année de
la révolution en train de vie jeune
femme
à la demande générale la parodie du
thierry par canal colonne de khon bravo
0 dans la série que sont ils devenus
pierre clémenti star des soixante dix
exclu
c'est le nouveau pasadena secondes noces
à la télé un best-of des films qui vous
filent et la fièvre samedi soir 100 %
pur sang spécial fixe est fantastique
après johnny comme les femmes young
cannibals reviennent vous bouffer tout
cru julien dray cause au petit juive
pied-noir député de l'essonne qui est
devenu le pâté m'imite excuses chatte et
à my back au new canchas des nous tourne
le dos on devient sado les laurel et
hardy du rock'n'roll chico d'agneau et
gros show business et rudes et rocks en
direct des chiottes du panache arnaud
bathroom singers à s'imposer non
night clubbing sylvain je gère la nuit
c'est la face cachée de la vie mesdames
messieurs jean paul chambas je suis
comme je suis bonne comme fétus la paix
tu là je fais le remix de dam dam et
j'en ai ma claque
et voici la star de la concurrence le
masure de masson on s'écroule de rire et
après on tombe à en ligne voici lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches l'émission
qui zappe tout seul citoyen
m
[Musique]
bruno masure bonsoir alors tu es le thé
le roi bon j'ai été inventé une nouvelle
forme est inventé une nouvelle forme de
présentation du journal télévisé avec
toujours comme ça des des petites vannes
mais c'était un peu prédestiné parce que
tu t'appelles masure tu bosses chez
bouygues via bon ça tout le monde l'aura
compris et en plus mon père était archi
tiger était s'invente pas
[Musique]
oh
chat qui s'appelle d'imad poids parce
que quand il est quand je l'aï eue tout
petit ils grossissent et chaque jour il
faisait des bonds formidable hérité la
voilà il était l'objet de mai mais
attention de chaque seconde
tu as lancé joseph poli puis tu fait des
plaisanteries et lancer léger du mérite
parce qu'il inscrit les loueurs bah
ouais et puis tu as aussi une grande
qualité c'est que tu es capable de dire
comme ça dans la conversation très
sérieusement tu parles de deuil que cela
vie tu dis que quelqu'un a fait des
commentaires acerbes et croates et
croate
et quand tu parles de l'autriche qui
disent ici voila voila mais ça ça parce
que bon ça passait très bien comme ça
pour ceux qui veulent te fais un livre
qui est formidable qui s'appelle la télé
en fumée mais je me soigne
ça n'a vendu combien en tout trois cent
trente sept ans elle sait bien
75001 je voudrais ouais je ne m'en sers
mais tu t'es fait combien tu es un max
de thune non je peux dire pour le moment
ils doivent encore de l'argent j'ai
touché très exactement 80 1 849 rend pas
plus non mais ils m'envoient avait
encore un peu je d'ailleurs je profite
du fait que je sois l'antenne pour
dire à monsieur plomb qui me wade
souchard astoria voilà exactement mais
tout ça ils payés rubis sur l'ongle
effectivement il ya 56 % de tout ça qui
va directement dans sa peau c'est normal
mais tout à fait un message et
sympathisants comme un peu juste non non
mais je serai le dernier à me plaindre
de payer des impôts
ouais tu sais que tu as quand même vendu
20 fois plus de livres que poivre
d'arvor la tient absolument fasciné je
veux pas te fâcher mais c'est fou quand
même temps j'ai fait le compte
mais elle a vendu parfois le sens
dernier livre le premier c'était très
bien vendu mais c'est pas la même non
mais leur romance et s'éteint une plage
difficile face à une concurrence folle
ouais donc c est gentil et les petits
camarades
ouais alors là tu en sors un autre chez
orban qui s'appelle à plein tube à la
7e' bien ce que ça veut dire
alors le sujet tu vas nous le raconter
parce que je veux comme tu es là pour
levante je vais pas faire le boulot à ta
place et ça mais bon c'est un groupe un
groupuscule qui s'appelle sus au paf
c'est ça hein et qui décide et des gens
voilà c'est un opuscule de
téléspectateurs mécontents est ce
possible
et qui pour faire aboutir ses légitimes
revendications comme dirait l'autre on
enlève successivement un patron de
chaîne 10 privée qui s'est faite gens
râlent genre voilà qui a une vie un peu
compliqué des moeurs spéciale à les
mines et dans tous les sens du terme
puis alors il ya réunion des pdg puis
ils n'aboutissent pas les revendications
ne sont pas franchement satisfait donc
qu'ils enlèvent une deuxième personne
qui est une animatrice productrice de
démission un petit peu de cul mais ça
aussi bien la verticale à c'est un peu
mon délire parce que tout ça n'existe
évidemment par la télévision française
voilà et puis ensuite comme ça marche
toujours pas ils enlèvent une troisième
personne qui est un animateur de jeu
bien connu
ces mauvais jobourg est ce que tu crois
pas quand même que le calembour
est possible à dose homéopathique dans
le 20 heures il est possible dans un
bouquin comme la télé rend fou mais je
me soigne
mais là quand on se trouve en face d'un
livre comme à plein tube qui n'est que
calembours parce qu'il n'y a pas le côté
souvenir que tu nous fais dans le
premier et seul trait l'atce les voyages
officiels et c est ce que tu crois pas
quand il ya que du calembour c'est un
peu lourd
c'est pas que du calembour parce que
d'abord il y en a il y en a des très
lourd mais il y en a de très subtil way
et d'autres frères merci vous aurez
droit au revenu en deuxième semaine
et d'autre part il ya bon toutes les
situations sont complètement folle
dingue mais tous les frais tous les
faits sont vrais tu crois pas quand même
que tu l'as fait un peu vite le nouveau
là non c'est pas mon sentiment je suis
un peu triste événement que ça donne
parce que j'y vais sur objet c'est
également le journal de 20h tu es pas
monter la tête ça c'est évident que
j'étais même un des seuls à qui ce n'est
pas monté à la tête
mais j'ai l'impression que le succès du
premier livre comme ça tu dis faut
battre le fer tant qu'il est chaud aux
blancs parce que justement je vais
essayer d'aider ma cause parce que si si
j'avais vu du justement bon refaire un
peu le tirage du premier j'aurais repris
justement la même formule ouais j'aurais
ajouté
voilà voilà j'aurai j'avais pas encore
raconté j'ai voulu faire complètement
autre chose justement faire une vraie
fiction est complètement inventé sur
inventé une histoire qui quoique bon
folle dingue est bon le parsemer
effectivement de jeux de mots plus ou
moins bon bonsoir révélation de l'année
de la rave
science et la continuité leur connaît
régulièrement de ses cendres trois
jeunes femmes 16 et 19 xiam j'ai qu'une
chose à vous dire bonjour
[Musique]
non
m
ja
[Musique]
m
c'est lui
chicken secours
à
[Musique]
et wendy jeunes ventes tv pour les
intimes bruno masure pourrait-il être
directeur du programme de tf1 première
chaîne française
premier examen reconnaître les gêner
avec des séries anglaises et américaines
j'ai entendu parler du blind test de
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche c'est
prêt je suis prêt à tout
star de la télé on t'a fait que des
génériques d'émissions de télé oui a
lancé le premier abord on ne souffle pas
le gentil on s'attendait
ça te rappelle quelque chose
mais on va pas passer tout disque non
non tu vas trouver là je vais pas prouvé
en fait je suis très ému non mais
franchement mais je dirais que je ne
connais que ça mais je
c'est la cassette qui s'autodétruit oui
instantanément
dans les jours impossible voilà voilà
mx ont alors moi je adacore dont on dit
qu un ah le voilà c'est beaucoup plus
drôle c était quoi ta miction la plus
indécise
et puis vague le sud ouest a fait
pendant la nuit ça c'est là une assise
trouve pas il est viré
le lait demain matin je vais faire
bouillir le lait alors ouais c'est
encore oui ces petits mangent ça passait
à dimanche trouverait à cet article
regarde et un prix
j'ai pas comment ça s'appelle le truc
sur le circuit
m
juste un jeu faire un aveu je regarde
jamais la télévision mais là c'est sûr
tu la regardes pas en semaine là non je
sais pas où tu reconnais pas ça non non
non c'est pas vrai c'est le vendredi
avant ton journal de temps en temps oui
mais je tombais je travaille moi c'est
muppet show
c'est un match à savoir
art mais c'est très mauvais j'avais
prévenu un astérix nom n'a mannix naniwa
tu sais applaudir quand
gas j'ai plongé oui c'est moi c'est bien
bon suivante main
[Musique]
jean-marie zarrouati
ou bien je garde ça passe sur terre
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous à tous les coups
cela dit
amicalement bien voilà
nul 1
c'est moi c'est génial tu regardes quoi
à la télé je c'est vrai que je regarde
plus tous les émissions d'information
avant oui je la toile d'armor voilà
maintenant plus d'un an que si le 30
avril une question suivante usap entre
les deux samedi 4 juin
non là où nantes aura tout fait oui
c'est georges guétary même
cette flèche devine georges décarie
bravo c'est monsieur carnaval au genou
nous remonterons jamais c'est vrai la
cjue talent c'est la seule émission de
télé où il à georges guétary bio vous
laissons lui impute la ville avait dû
rater un peu alors j'ai mis sur l'europe
où il ya georges guétary veut pas dire
c'est qu'il n'ya non j'adore mais ça
c'est dur à trouver ses homonymes avec
un fabricant de meubles de salle
ça si tu trouves tu passes ton devrait
pas beaucoup c'est à l'hiver oui non je
venais pas l'hiver reconnaître que la
mission a baissé pour tous traîné par
coeur mais ça va
la semelle
m
c'est magnifique et venir à bout
c'est bien la 10e marque pas mal de gens
finalement dans martha my way sans
plaisir poli
sous le climat qui fait chanter pour le
dow
ouais
gand
[Musique]
ce soir en soi une femme toujours jeune
simone veil et puis la coupe de france a
une super sympa david et jonathan cimade
super mais je te tutoie
oui mon garçon gimone tu t'es déjà fait
reculer sinon je peux vous aimez les
questions franche directe sans ambages
et réponses aussi vu la réponse est
venue peu plus tard qu hier soir et
demain j'ai pu pousser le mouvement
favorisant la pratique sodomie d'accord
david et jonathan je vous demande pas ce
que j'avais fait pour les vacances n'est
pas un peu gros sinon j'ai trop vu mon
ordi ça parce qu'on m'a dit que vous
preniez de la coke
qu'est ce qui t'a dix ans les frères
nakache les frères macache maurice en
cash pour qu il est mort il sera chez
huawei
ils ont assimilé l'afro beat hip hop et
le techno rap à ses fans qui découle de
la grosse pomme en passant par juvisy
voici pourquoi dans lunettes blanches
neo chorio de serre et c'est la pana
[Musique]
bon alors simone je lis dans libé que tu
vas dans les boîtes une ans tu as in
house
comment vous faites surtout la musique
classique
christian il faut que je fais ma
consommation
mais j'ai rien vu dès que je peux
voilà on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vie noir
avec un tipi de piles mais les
confessions érotique de jean lecanuet et
pilleurs a également su marceau qui nous
parlera des glières salut bande de nazes
et n'oubliez pas pour les yeux rouges
elle vaut une paire de lunettes blanches
michael mann
[Musique]
oh
our money des sceaux à chauvigny slap
[Musique]
chop that is hemingway d'asséner des
nantis
[Musique]
il est choqué en occident comme weekly
famous modal you got you and mail de la
toupie de modèles phares de fabricom pas
une babe 28 go studio pour évoquer
niveau
[Musique]
c'est de la poésie des new lipstick fait
lyonnais
[Musique]
pailloux
dieu et de son dynamisme
là
innover c'est amazing her music hall
manhattan baby einstein home in paris
2009 gary coleman accouché cette chose à
ta té lé forcing ternie
[Musique]
ces choses-là territoriaux divorce
daigne began to le livre de l'anglais
lewsey began to drink to smoke
[Musique]
aucune excuse d'animateur de blaise est
de lister l'ordre laminé ly sin romano
[Musique]
les vitraux yu myung hwan 600 kg des 10
titres la carie beurre
[Musique]
des senteurs
donnez château d'eau château
[Musique]
et sam
peter regin santé
[Musique]
pierre clémenti bonsoir ça fait plaisir
de te voir aussi ça fait quoi de
retrouver le palace qu o
une grande joie tout j'ai connu le poste
début où il y avait le baiser copie qui
s'appelait une très belle pièce avec
j'aurais pu et il est bien sûr comme
c'est très beau et après le palace est
devenu l'endroit qui l'équipent vertu
interprète une pièce en ce moment en
fait tu va interpréter à partir du 14
janvier une pièce à avignon à l'opéra
d'avignon et fameux marat sade
où est peter weiss qu'on a vu à l'époque
tu tiens le rôle de deux marins qui dans
ma vie où j'ai langage une gratte tu
attends sur le corner j'ai trop cher
votre cure des wii en toi aussi tu as eu
une vie très très tourmentée très belle
très romanesque
tu viens d'un milieu assez assez proche
quoi tu étais blouson noir quand on
était jeunes mans
[Musique]
issu d'un milieu très modeste si je me
mets revenaient de corse et à l'époque
les mecs laban l'époque c'était les
bretons et corses mais est bon
je suis un enfant naturel et
j'ai une
l'université de la rue est alors un jour
tu as de jouer dans une dramatique télé
est quelqu'un qui est à remarquer
visconti chercher quelqu'un et tu t'es
retrouvé en face de visconti saint saëns
et je me suis retrouvé devant oui j'ai
lu il change et au sens de la rue
blanche dans les mots et oui j'avais eu
la chance comme le lecteur de faire deux
oppositions c'est à dire faire
l'émission de noël qui étaient des gens
pas ce qui est flagrant flore et lazard
higazi ce qu'avait fait on est tellement
seul qui rique nouvelles de pauwels et
là je faisais un buso loire et l'autre
je faisais un prince mort donc entend
engager dans le guépard comme prince
voilà et quand visconti tu as vu il a
dit mais qu'est ce que ce mec-là va
faire que comme prince et toi tu arrives
en lui montrant thema weeps en lui
disant est-ce que c'est pas des mânes
prince il était très bon et a peu
bouleversé parce que j'étais noir où
j'avais les cheveux très très noir et
blanc et blond cendré ou quelqu'un de
très fragile
un peu comme dans la mort à venise et je
suis mon tribut humain city et ça a
marché
sa manche et a eu une carrière
absolument énorme qui a commencé avec
adorablement 2 avec les films de bunuel
la voie lactée et puis la belle de jour
surtout bien sûr les benjamins avec la
compagnie et puis je fais beaucoup de le
filmer caméra hommes avec
cavani avec pasolini aussi bien tu leur
chez les pros j'ai beaucoup de chance
en 72 kg et est considéré comme comme
l'artiste le plus important enfin moi je
m'en souviens très bien de la génération
c'était vraiment ans c'est là qu'il a
commencé à voir des problèmes quoi parce
que sais tu
première fois 169 quand tu es parti en
italie justement pour voir le porcherie
porte chez les deux films de pasolini
médée problème à relayer tu t'es fait
arrêter pour aujourd'hui je pense que ça
sera vraiment souri le jir a tenu chez
ram
paul louis eux
à l'époque je ne buvaient pas d'alcool
je sais ça lui fait mal de chine tu fous
merde
les voilà était archi partie des comme
baudelaire né en à lautréamont que cette
ces gens qui se sont pas différencier et
qui rumine eux
une culture total à travers à travers
les les risques qu'ils ont pris dans
leurs vies dès l'initiation mais c'est à
étonner quand les douaniers de sont
tombés dessus comme ça tu étais dans un
univers où c'était pas grave ou tu
t'attendais à ce que ma disons qu'ils
mangent des grands cible je ne sais pas
parce que à l'épaule qui ont fumé du
shit c'était en réaction de d'avoir vu
nos parents c'est noir du rouge et roué
de coups parce qu'ils avaient un petit
duo emmené là c'est là où c'est devenu
beaucoup plus grave 172 en italie un
jour tu vivais chez une copine à rome et
le matin les flics sont arrivés les
filiales évoque la législation italienne
était très très dure puisque ont
considéré les consommateurs comme les
trafiquants oui et puis tu t'es
carrément fait arrêter jeu là tu t'es
retrouvé dans la dans la prison une des
prisons les plus dures du monde c'est ok
c'est napoléon qui a construit chine est
celle imaginée la galicienne oui je
vivais chez quelqu'un et puis s'est
avéré que toi en italie j'étais
quelqu'un de très suivie de très écouté
même dans les médias et que quelquefois
je dépassait les bornes par mes
interviews les déclarations que je
faisais et le jour où ils ont pu
me prendre dans un mode écoute on
ignorait quand après il ya eu le procès
vient quand même fait 17 mois de taule
dans des conditions n'étaient pas des
jours n'était pas toujours drôle non non
parce que c'était à l'époque où où il se
passait des choses la mort de moreau les
brigades oranges
ouais ça bougeait très fort en italie et
bon du tout il y avait toute une gt avec
toute une génération de gens de mon âge
qui beaucoup d'étrangers aussi qu'y
pouvons répéter un prenez deux ans qu'on
voit la vue quand il est en procès c'est
des gens comme fellini comme vittorio de
sica qui sont venus qui ont attendu
pendant des heures dans le couloir
jusqu'à ce qu'ils puissent venir plaider
et dire enfin vous n'allez pas le garder
en tôle et c'est quoi c'était c'était
assez assez fort à l'époque moi je sais
qu'on était tous très concernés par par
ton sort mais si tu le savais pas
d'ailleurs la loi italienne a été changé
huit jours après ton procès cirque on a
arrêté la considérer la loi et fait
mentir et arrêter de considérer les
trafiquants et les consommateurs comme
comme la même chose finale compliqué tu
crois pas que cette que cette période
que tu vas passer en prison
complètement brisé sa carrière à
l'époque et sponsors tu vois pas
maintenant je pense que dans ce cas
précis un buffet ce genre de film qui
peut-être ne correspondait pas j'en sais
rien mais c'est fait a pu fait les films
avec bunuel avec una campagne avec deux
villes
étaient tournés vers des choses plus
underground tu as fait ton bouquin
d'abord et puis ensuite tu t'es tourner
vers des portes a fait des courts
métrages et puis tu es allé vers garrel
vers des gens comme ça oui
d'ailleurs quand j'ai pas vu quand j'ai
eu en remplissant original où arrivait
bien je me suis vraiment posé le
problème si en définitive je sortais
j'avais juste sortie à 33 ans je suis
rentré et rentrer en france a tenu tout
113,46 sont maintenant et que je après
cette expérience bouleversante que
j'avais suivi parce que j'étais vraiment
aussi dans une autre université qui
était et elle à l'anarchie qui étaient
50% des gens arrêtés en plus cela pour
des raisons politiques
dk société et quand je suis sorti de la
maison je me suis vraiment demandé si
j'avais le désir de continuer alors que
je savais pertinemment qu'une page était
tournée dans ma vie une page aussi au
cinéma était et est traversée de cette
évolution humaine de ces révolutions qui
avait quand même été une très grande
manifestation dans le dans une mutation
pour la jeunesse et et des gens comme
moi qui qui allait devenir adulte
puisque on les avait on avait essayé de
les briser de les mettre au pas de les
casser
et puis je suis sorti 2
les maisons on avait immédiatement
j'étais la profession en france a été
très gentille a essayé très vite de me
remettre sur les rails mais j'avais plus
de plaisir c'est importé quoi la drogue
beaucoup de choses moi j'ai travaillé
j'ai traversé la période de la cie par
exemple on attend je reprenais plus
d'acides parce que j'ai eu une overdose
acide
gg j'ai connu aussi j'ai connu les
rolaco que j'ai fait beaucoup aussi
d'asiles psychiatriques l'astuce tout ça
crée un déséquilibre par rapport aux bas
par rapport aux familles 20 par rapport
aussi aux gens avec lesquels tu
travailles s'est accrue aussi un travail
aussi c'est que toi tu traverses des
gouffres tuer vous plus sensibiliser et
attirer vers la mort la maladie que de
2,2 sur jdd d'émerger de et de pouvoir
aussi retrouvé une satisfaction dans la
création
bon c'est un peu des maladies d'enfance
beaucoup à la rougeole la scarlatine de
cette génération avec la droite comme il
a une autre qui regarde absolument parce
que quand iberia vais l'absinthe
williams vélo d'allonnes le talonne en
vente dans les pharmacies à côté habib
thiam et la codéine s'était pas interdit
à l'époque les gens je crois pas qu'il y
ait beaucoup plus de toroguhé qu' il y
avait l'opium appartenait to put in tout
une petite minorité d'anciens diplomates
qui travaillaient ou en asie au
moyen-orient et casar c'est ouais ouais
bon il ya eu il ya eu cette espèce de
raz-de-marée de partant parce que la
jeunesse a été attirée bien vers
l'orient parce que ici on ne pensait qu
à faire ont pensé qu'à l'argent et que
c'était
les ir du vietnam la fin de la guerre de
l'algérie la jeunesse avait un autre
regard été témoin du leur propre leur
propre désir de de l'eau propre
reconnaissance de se reconnaître cessé
mais déjà ce que ça t'a apporté on peut
le voir mais ce que ça t'a enlevé ça n'a
pas enlevé le désir d'être star tu dis
là
la notoriété m'a coûté trop cher pour
que je la regrette de toute façon je
n'ai jamais voulu être star si c'était à
refaire je referais alors c'est tout
pareil après la révolution chez krivine
et l'antiracisme avec harlem julien dray
s'est lancé dans la politique pour
lunettes il se pose lui-même les
questions que tout le monde se pose à
son sujet
c'est en cet été conseiller dû qu'à
l'étagé c'est une tradition familiale
d'être conseiller du prince
visiblement je poursuive dans la
tradition familiale on va voir ce que ça
va donner
tu veux être premier ministre un jour je
sais pas est ce à ce sujet pas de
réponse encore à cette question à qui tu
aurais bien ressembler quand tu étais
petit hélas
enfin la tulipe aujourd'hui thé député
ps de l'essonne est ce que tu es pas
déçu de ne pas avoir été secrétaire
d'état à la jeunesse
ça serait malhonnête de dire j'ai pas
été déçu j'ai été déçu oui comme tout le
monde parce que j'avais envie de faire
un certain nombre de choses et que
participer à un gouvernement suit le
gouvernement de gauche après lui mais
c'était intéressant ceci dit le travail
des députés plutôt passionnant ce dont
tu as passé dix ans de sa vie à la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire d'alain
krivine ça a servi à quoi ça a servi à
apprendre à faire des manifestations à
faire des concerts à faire des fêtes
et puis ça m'a donné aussi d'un certain
nombre de convictions sur l'organisation
de la société
je renie rien de ce que j'ai fait à
cette époque là au contraire
et tu crois au complot trotskiste autour
du chef de l'état toi j'ai vu dans un
hebdomadaire récemment effectivement il
y avait un caricaturiste qui avait fait
un portrait de mitterrand qui est en
train d'écrire il ya rocard qui rentrait
vide qu'est ce que j'apprends vous est
prescrit
bon je crois que c'est le degré de la
situation mon nom et mon je crois pas
qu'elle complot 36 je crois que c'est
effectivement une génération qui après
68 a milité dans les rangs d
organisation trotskyste qui est un
vivier
cette génération est arrivée à maturité
je crois qu'elle continue pour une
partie de ces individus
le combat qu'elle a commencé à mener l
eau continue sous des formes plus
efficace et le parti socialiste en étude
vous parlez de quoi quand tu vois
mitterrand ça je le dire pour moi si
demain mitterrand parce que j'ai un
camion du soutien qu'ils ont
je touche du bois
quand il ya la presse que julien dray
est en vacances pour une semaine il
regarda être tranquille tu en penses
quoi
non je pense que c'est pas un individu
comme moi un petit juive pied noir qui
peut fragiliser le gouvernement rocard
dont j'ai exprimé un certain guy déjà
bousculé un certain nombre de choses je
crois que c'est bien c'est nécessaire
parce qu'on peut pas dormir sur ses
lauriers il faut réfléchir il faut
qu'ils les impertinents et puis si c'est
pas les jeunes ceux qui aujourd'hui
cette situation-là qui le fond qui va le
faire quand elle revenir en 65
tu étais désolé pas remis les pieds
noirs qui étaient déjà arrivés en france
depuis soixante-dix tettey aussi isolé
parmi les français et aujourd'hui tout
sens commun la plus tôt dans un courant
majoritaire
même si c'est pas encore ça mais plutôt
dans un courant majoritaire c'est j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt la volonté
aujourd'hui de représenter tout le monde
tu es le fondateur de la soliste racisme
quand il s'agit tous déclarent que
l'occupation de la judée samarie
c'est salir la mémoire de l'holocauste
tu vis à comment je crois qu'il faut pas
confondre les choses que le low cost
c'est le low cost ces six millions de
juifs détruit ce la destruction d'un
peuple
ce qui n'excuse pas aujourd'hui la
situation du peuple palestinien je crois
que comme tout juif je suis écorché
aujourd'hui par la situation du peuple
palestinien et je voudrais de tout mon
coeur qu'on puisse résoudre ce problème
rapidement
imagine tu es une guerre entre la france
israël tu saurais décale côté du côté de
mon pays c'est la france
mais je souhaite pas qu'il y ait entre
israël et la france
[Musique]
content de ta vie jusqu'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il ya des choses
avec lesquelles je serais plutôt
satisfaits des choses avec lesquelles le
geoffrey pas qu'aux stars ont pourriture
avec téléphone cravate était atteint du
syndrome julie ou quoi d'abord jacques
une r5 pas 1h25
donc ça donne déjà des prêts - alou
particulier deuxièmement bon je crois
que ce serait démagogique de dire qu'il
faut qu un élu n'est pas des moyens pour
travailler parce qu'on peut pas
reprocher un élu de ne pas faire son
travail et en même temps ne pas lui
donner les moyens
donc je crois que la cravate c'est
obligatoire c'est les gens qui vous
force à peut-être voir si on n'a pas la
cravate n'est pas représentants on n'est
pas député il faut accepter les choses
ex tissus batiks arnaud on avait adoré
jive to the beat l'année dernière là ils
chantent bathroom saignant et la face b
du 45 tours c'est le tango dans la peau
nous en avons dans la peau qui a bien
d'autres points communs avec jacques
brel que sa belgitude
comme disait le président léopold sédar
senghor qui sera sûrement avec nous le
24 janvier à l'elysée montmartre pour le
concert d'arno chinois
[Musique]
en live
jérôme ses toiles à signaler
gyza fraudeurs
[Musique]
accro aux réseaux
gironde jm.a
chapeau
je pars au sénégal
[Musique]
non
she's a aboli
la chine garde le moral
[Musique]
non dit
comme jamais
au suisse à paris
[Musique]
oh
voici en vidéo
le monsieur cinéma du rock'n'roll
ban
dialysés vie n'est pas
j'avais applaudir comme philippe gildas
pareil voilà les bonnes là car elle est
bonne en laye arabes ont alors qu'ils
gros show qui est shiko shiko ce gros
alors tu vois je compte les gauchos
c'est le faux maigre
d'accord vous êtes connus comme ans tous
les deux ouais voilà c'est long c'est
vieux au début les années 60 une phase
début des années 70 - réalisateur europe
1 lui attaché de presse
c'était le début de mer entre vous n'y a
rien de sexuel n'ya rien n'arrête pas
d'enfant malade sa c'est en mer semble m
ouais et sur antenne 2 donc c'est izard
c'est bizarre ça se passe mais avant il
a été blanchi en quarts ouais
et depuis ces deux buts et deezer vous
avez dit bizarre oui 25 milliards bon
d'accord il qu'ils soient je me suis
posé je dois laisser le bouton ouvert ou
fermé 6e ouvert ça fait ça fait
tennisman fermé ça fait cliché mardi son
sac affaton paulo
alors on commence il n'est pas loin
encore j'aime recommence avec les one
hit wonder
oui a pas besoin de sous titres mais
walid rondeurs voilà alors on va y aller
on va y aller avec toi oui alors tu te
souviennes ou l'éboulis bien sûr ça me
touche à main de faro la réponse 1965
et adapté par au bonheur des dames
j'aimerais qu'on arrêtait rouler bourré
rouler bourré alors toi line tyne 6/3 66
et une marocaine de mystérieux on
continue avec les one hit wonder
isocyanates heinui mungo jerry 67 lundi
alors hollandais décembre 69 ça c'était
ou de 70 puis été prêt allons-y vinès
finesse shocking blue bras groupe
je tiens à préciser luc hollandais
volant d abord ne peut pas faire un peu
plus dur maintenant on va faire les
frères mais qui vont par trois alors
dites moi un groupe californien où il ya
trois frères il ya trois un groupe
californien où il ya trois frères ou les
beach boys voilà les trois wilson ryan
car il y en a qui est mort il ya deux
ans ryan car les dennis voilà bon à toi
maintenant un groupe en anglais il ya
trois frères un groupe anglais où il ya
trois frères c'est pas les beatles n'a
ça j'en suis sûr c'est pas les beatles
un groupe anglais où il ya trois frères
c'est tombé sur lui les a c'est pas
grosse non vraiment ils sont pas anglais
anglais
à give my tongue tous de cannes le
groupe anglais il ya trois frères
contamine demain matin au téléphone
c'est vrai excusez moi je m'en vais là
j'ai seulement
je ne savais pas ben c'est les bee gees
mes enfants ils sont pas très bien juste
naissant guitare et centre ont fait leur
début de carrière en australie sont
thierry jouer tu peux en donnant le nom
des trois frères d'abord robin way
maurice ouais et
attention là c'est le premier cabinet
sais pas ce qu'en dit c'était le
quatrième est décédé mais non je vais
aller plus loin que ça je vais même dire
l'origine du mot bitches pour ceux qui
ne le savent pas là alors b g ça veut
dire brothers gibb et voilà il
s'appelait guide mon salut fans
mouloudéens répondu si je pollue pas
alors maintenant d'affaires encore plus
cultivés on va faire les films basés sur
le roc où il ya des groupes de rock qui
sont les vedettes des films alors à toi
200 dreams the same c'est une bonne
question
ouais merci de me l'avoir posé et reposé
the songs remain the same and auction
tout je dois répondre quoi tu dois
répondre le titre du groupe
collé collé verrouille très bien coller
pourquoi tant de haine à la guerre comme
à la guerre
les dix plus mon petit moi c'est un peu
chez huawei ah bah ouais ça m'a jamais
trop accroché j'ai été vraiment un
sixties
non non non mais où les epide moins pas
au boulot tu te lèves et non il avouait
alors toi maintenant tu sais le world's
aubin les pink floyd
non non non non non non the last oui bah
oui que ça vient un peu plus dur grand
bien lui fasse
bien sûr bon de l'instrument
alalalala grâce et un fusil c'est pas
non non non non non non non non ben
voilà et grand bien lui fasse
alors maintenant quand le super pactole
on va faire les supergroupes alors si je
te dis un groupe où il ya 2 buffalo
springfield c'est à toi un alizé un bird
2 buffalo springfield à alise est en
berne avec un y flâne britos brevets
menacent et palais brito 2 2 buffalo
springfield réalise
et un beurre avec un y fait pas la liste
d'antoine qui mélangent dans le lard y
est les burns a écrit oh lalala lalala
n'ont pas ces pages rend là-bas c'est ce
livre est que ces grosses pièces
détachées
crosby ménage c'est le lisez moi j'ai
une question est posée
sheila de son vrai nom annie chancel
chante sous un pseudonyme lequel j
arrive à la deuxième question
ouais marvin gaye huy hà tinh enregistré
we can't get to witness avant ou après
sa mort aujourd'hui alors que laisser
les questions courantes à gourin non non
non non par exemple le nom de claude
françois est composé de prénom mais on a
des très belles et continue avec son
bien quel est le lien de parenté des
isley brothers le même que celui des
verts les water ou des allemands c'est
la très compliqué super pactole leur
toit bah ouais si oui bien si my
sister's note de boyle way est ce que
james taylor is rich m'a pas vraiment je
vais me venger
un groupe où il ya un nice un king
crimson et un atomic rooster ça fait 3
presse personne qui ait fait aimer son
lac est pas là mais ouais
emerson lake and palmer qui avait fait
une version génial de blue rondo à la
turk et oui le dave brubeck dit non tu
connais pas les prénoms la 6eme sun will
take away et attend alalala tu veux pas
la mère si c'est pas robert s'est séparé
c'est pas celui qui est chez bijoux mon
plein à savoir un autre palmer john par
manas peter albert n'a jamais vu ses
petits
c'est karl vous applaudir auquel je dois
donner les lunettes
j'en avais déjà tous les deux ces
caisses qui a gagné ses procès le jeu on
sait pas qui est ce qui n est pas comme
chez martin on n'est pas tous
s'exécutait pas comme l'école des fans à
mérite pas non bah oui ça c'est un bon
pilote et un doigt la moitié musiques
didier lockwood parents -les etienne
roda-gil margaux hemingway champ de
fiches riders and world
pour la petit d'hemingway le glas a bien
failli sonner mais elle a préféré se
servir de ses cordes vocales plutôt que
de se tirer une balle dans la bouche
comme son grand père
voilà watts
[Musique]
il a
vva
[Musique]
non
mais
m
texte
j'adore
parce qu'à nord
michalon
ici
m
[Musique]
allez
mais
once à l'aise
j'adore
ce cadeau
[Musique]
le rock'n'roll c'est beaucoup plus que
de la musique et lunettes le prouve
chaque samedi soir avec son interview
pinceau ce soir jean paul chambas je
perds en écoutant jim morrison
[Musique]
en jean paul chambas depuis le 6 janvier
1989 et les pièces au jardin d'hiver qui
s'appelle la nuit les chats mise en
scène par jean pierre vincent ils ont
taffé la scénographie oui en plein moi
je dis plutôt décor je préfère dire des
camps spéciaux décors et costumes
ouais parce que comme je suis peintre
préfère dire déclarait ce contrat ainsi
nos graphistes et en mots qui me tient
peu gerber près des corps
tu as beaucoup voyagé avant de devenir
jean paul chamblas tu étais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé avec dali à callac
l'espace pour la france oui mais il sera
caméra explore non mais c'est vrai
c'était mais quand on a 17 ans gars m'a
toujours intéressé par ce genre de
personnage je m'étais retrouvé à
cadaquès je devais aller pour lui devait
être mais quand j'avais cheveux très
longs entre hold-up atteindre la cible
sans doute aussi le rapport aux sujets
et donc comme ça remarque à la cadac
espagne par dali je fais des croquis je
me prenais un peu pour un artiste tu
auras sur dingue
et il m'a pris je suis allé chez lui on
a commencé à voir les choses comme ça
dégoûtant de tannhauser le soleil qui se
couche et énervé et il m'a pris comme
assistant je reste ne va pas dans quel
état va même temps au prêt de six mois
car je suis à l aise que des départs
le jour où j'ai dit à ma soeur que le
livre est un cadeau quand je serai
célèbre mais jamais ils n'ont été
connues qu'en mais enfin je sais pas moi
je t'ai connu à l'époque sans qu elle n
est salée portrait la compta fait ça
allait de malcom lowry a alloué en
passant par malraux et jim morrison the
way lacroix j'ai pris de bons sujets non
c'est à dire que je me suis aperçu
parfaite après que c'était d'aider des
sujets relativement dramatique même
puisque j'ai eu la trouille parce que le
soir du vernissage
gerald et tous ces portraits comme ça et
je m'étais très troublée je me suis
aperçu qu'ils étaient touche manque de
mort violente
dur alors il ya un jour comme ça et
j'avais pas proposé de faire une expo
dans une ville puisque vous venez d'en
faire une enfin les tiers partis aussi
une histoire fantastique du rpt parti
d'une gifle que tu avais donné une fille
à marrakech
oui mais c'était une sorte de
culpabilité une connerie comme ça par
ariane plus qu'un câble et c'est ce qui
va nous tenir éveillés cité peter
hancock et cédéthèque moyens café
attendait tous se disent ah mais oui
c'était effectivement alors au maroc une
drôle d'histoire comme ça brûle d'amour
des jalousies choqué comme jaloux je
suis du sud merde c'est vrai et
c'était parti quand j'étais con et
comment que ces absurdités de commandos
de ça et comment expliques-tu choses là
et avec cette fille catherine on sait on
a ici de comprendre ce qui s'était passé
un petit peu et j'essaie d'en faire une
exposition est en fait c'est une fiction
qu on a recréé après après cette réalité
et je vais vous dire c'est le truc j'ai
demandé à petter en quête de me faire
les titres avant même d'avoir fait les
dessins et en fait peut-être que ça
voulait dire que j'avais pas
d'imagination
ce qui fait qu'il m'a vachement aider il
m'a beaucoup aidé et j'ai créé cette
série de douze dessins qui étaient
autant de lettres de croquis mais a
grandi à des formats et non et c'était
donc j'ai entier il ya eu un livre
heureusement il a de l'avis de la
fiction et wes édité chez hbo mois là et
je crois que ça c'est juste comme ça
alors tu as des seules banques qui est
passé quand même disons de la peinture
au théâtre que tu as commencé à faire
des tableaux en trois dimensions tu t'es
mis à faire du départ de théâtre ouais
ça c'est un drôle de chose parce que
c'est
on dit toujours que c'est dangereux que
l'état ne faut pas qu'il fasse trop ça
et je l'écris randonnée puis maintenant
il me semble que si on considère le
décor comme une vraie création
c'est-à-dire les mêmes angoisses les
mêmes expliqué m
la même solitude je crois que les décors
peut être vu en lui même comme une
oeuvre d'art tout ce travail de jean
pierre vincent avait claude régy exim
wanders oui mais on entre à salzbourg
sur les pistes de vétérans plein sur ce
qu'il perde formidable parce que anne
qui n'avait même pas fini d'écrire la
pièce vive ne savais même pas ce qu'il
avait fait avec mise en scène et moi je
sais pas ce que je vais faire comme
décor et tous les trois on a travaillé
on a fait cette espèce de pâte et
quelques montées
c'est vrai qu'il ait jamais les textes
quand tu fais un dessin décors et
costumes
c'est vrai j'ai ouï oui c'est très bien
c'est un peu vrai mais c'est vrai qu'il
change tout dernier moment je sais plus
quand est-ce que tu as encore tout
changer la fin mais oui parce que la
générale quand tu fais une maquette qui
bêlent et qui plaît à tout le monde tout
le monde est content on a un peu
l'impression d'être un peu le bon élève
de la classe attendait de toi voilà oui
ça m'agace beaucoup et en général dans
la nuit je le blues yves jean lacasse et
j'ai téléphoné vincent rouaix qui chaque
fois bloody du surveillant et puis oui
ça marche je suis peut-être pas
tellement les hyper réaliste un tu dis
des mecs qui passent trois plans pour
paiement nombre le squat je vois pas
l'intérêt
j'apprendrai chier si on peut en trois
coups de crayon rendent beaucoup mieux
qu'en faisant 40 ombre callander détails
elle me tend la main à voir c'est un peu
ça la figuration libre non plus que
cette idée mais qui vont peindre sur les
routes des stylistes pour qu'on les voit
dans l'immédiate la teinture ses plus
sérieuses la porte si bon plus graves
à oui mesdames surtout comme j'écris moi
que ça pouvait être comme ça évite le
chimiste floraison cette espèce de truc
doit y avoir un peu de jalousie de temps
mais quand j'ai vu ça je me suis dit
qu'il fallait trophée cy young et je
refuse une venue j'aimerais bien
franchement qui tu effaces si tu étais
pas jean paul chamblas tout va être je
peux choisir dans toute l'histoire de
gasquet à bâle alors il vaut mieux
anglais de l'inspecter influencerait
partie mais curieusement effectué par
danic sommes au début mais bon même
jamais tiré du tout maintenant
certainement par bacon
et en fait j'aimerais surtout le choisir
mes influences et santiago
c'est difficile mais j'aimerais choisir
piero della francesca
le silence la tranquillité et tu as des
choses qui donne une respiration et qui
donne un vrai plaisir aux gens de ne pas
être seulement son propre créateur mais
donner la possibilité aux autres c'est
un rêve que les télécréateurs en
regardant la chose ça c'est tough guy
paris par ghazi balance un nom parce que
j'ai vu ce nom mais pas copier dans la
peinture vraiment m'aider dans les pubs
ça c'est terrible
speedy sont faits pour ça mais quand
même t'écoutes quoi qu'on tue pas
piano quand je travaille sur quelqu'un
comme bien de nous il faut que j'essaie
de faire une série de tableaux sur red
bull racing et on trouve beaucoup de les
doors et beauxis et redonne donc l
histoire c'est vrai que tu vas le voir
au père lachaise de temps en temps non
tu s'agitait j'étais assez cohérent et
lui afin qu'ils
avant qu'il meure et non je suis jamais
allé en fait
je ne ferai pas
du pognon
non suffisamment probants des dettes
ouais mais tu clak tu vas aux critiques
la cabine qui t'attendent devant la zéro
point c'est vrai tout ça pour toi et toi
oui j'allais faire un trou et en même
temps oui s'il devait rester une
définition de toi dans dictionnaire des
peintres que ce soit quoi enfin bon
d'épitaphe soit au père lachaise
jean paul chambas de points c'est comme
quand des bombes boucherie chicon l'ont
reconnu dans le érudit rock c'est sam la
honte et les pharaons
taureaules et ne rouler bourré après le
succès de la guette des rois grand
retour des soirées costumées aubin ici
c'était cherchent ils m'ont impossible
amour l'invité d'honneur désormais
jean-claude la grèce va frapper deux
fois par mois on passe aux news annie
cordy sort un album de ses principaux
succès en house music
la bonne du curé façon yahoo
rod stewart à ta classe ayant justice
elle utiliserait certaines de ses
chansons pour envoyer des messages codés
à des agents planqué derrière le rideau
de fer
moneyball et où aller voler chez vous
comme ça le pote de devenir au stade de
la porte de clichy grand match de foot
les crâneuse contre les modeuses
ça aussi c'est du night clubbing
mesdames messieurs chez les verbes
frédéric lorca l'attaché de presse de
gauthier et catherine me rend celle de
kookaï chez les rouges paquita pas qu'un
vague et alexia silvani glamour dans les
tribunes martine sitbon eva truffaut
michel klein claude challe résultats
attaché de presse trois rédactrices de
mode zéro
[Musique]
le cac à ce club des analphabètes con
mais attachant plus philippe corti qui
ne l'est pas moins
ont organisé leur nouvel an russe à la
java avec la cèze nec dans la série les
news de lunettes qui tue johnny hallyday
prépare son prochain album avec étienne
roda-gil ça s'appelle cadillac c'est
l'histoire d'un môme qui part de
cadillac et qui font de la ville de
detroit
exclu lui l'amerloque qui nous refait le
coup de la môme pias paul sound and
filmé par sylvain jobs a battu l'as
mathieu
tout d'abord je vais
et
mais
imaginé par jean michel gravier
nostalgie et marie claude beaud quartier
solex nostalgie du 15 janvier au 23
février à la fondation cartier
jouy-en-josas ici robert-hossein si une
son solex racheté par quartier 130 mille
francs pour les restaurants du coeur
présence panchounette a décidé de
quartier risée son solex en le trempant
dans leur fin et en demandant aux
fournisseurs de quartier la sellerie
oh
retour aux sparadraps pour eric deetman
console ex
claude lévêque gendarmes et guignol sans
oublier marc couturier le reflet d'un
solex dans de l'eau césar 5 solex pour
sa compression france val est la seule
femme de l'expo elle a mis le moteur son
porte-bagages
le système de jean clar bout ces trois
moteurs et une roue pour le mettre en
marche il faut
marie claude beaud jean dominique perrin
et l'artiste
un beau parent
on
armand il lui a fallu cas de solex mais
c'est pas mal
m
[Musique]
richard baquié ce n'est que sont castrés
dans des plaques de verre bp
[Musique]
oh
une histoire de lui l'un des meilleurs
skoda ça s'appelle 160 262 be dans un
verre exclu après tom jones qui fait un
malheur avec keith de prins plus art of
noise c'est fou ce qu'on apprend qu'un
truc dans cette émission voici petula
clark et que fais tu là petula what do
you do d'art je fais leur imx de
downtown et j'en ai ma clark encore une
vanne comme ça et tu es viré connard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
bon
m
il
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
salut bande de nazes il est temps de
sortir et comme dirait de koné 0 contre
les lunettes noires les yeux rouges
y'a que ça de vrai
[Musique]
on va
oui
m
bah
là bas
ad
[Musique]
et on va
et corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu